why would you do this to us
the belching beaver breweries
peanutbutter flavored milk stout cuz
it's all about the beaver peanut butter
that should be interesting
malt oats lactose hops yeast and natural
natural flavors kind of smells like a
Reese's Pieces Wow I'm diggin I'm diggin
it I'm diggin it nice peanut buttery I
don't know it's a too early to go 5 out
of 5 right out of the gate high water
brewing campfire stout leaves you
wanting s'more it evokes fond memories
of wilderness and camping adventures
we'll see
with graham crackers wow this is oh yeah
oh yeah it smells like candy yeah smells
like candy I know it's not taste like
don't include that hmm amazing yeah
that's really good no I'm not getting
s'more out of this at all out of one out
of five one one lemon chiffon cruller
ale sorry we've already had a couple
beers don't mind if I do
what is chiffon lemon chiffon I could
not is it this style of doughnut Nadine
I feel like a chiffon is a nice like
scarf a lady wears
oh that looks like dehydrated pea
lemonade lemon cake it seriously smells
like cleaning fluid it does oh you don't
like it no oh I like it
doughnut should be a doughnut and a beer
should be a beer this banana bread beer
I've heard about this one bread beer
because long ago ale was known as liquid
bread huh Wow you know it's not even
just banana bread it's the yellow Laffy
Taffy which is my favorite Laffy Taffy
nope I don't like it I don't like it
my car
like it no it tastes like banana candy
when you see banana bread beer you want
some [ __ ] banana bread yeah exactly
this you're right I like it
I think this would give you a tummy ache
why flavor something unless it's better
than normal beer but you don't do if you
claim to be double chocolate this is
gonna be good as hell its award-winning
it doesn't say what award it won that's
a nice bottle that was like Willy Wonka
okay Oh nope you don't like I don't like
it yes yes no Mallory's wrong I hate
chocolate no that's so good what would
you pair it with the turkey leg it's not
soo chocolatey though no all these big
braggadocious flavors double chocolate
I don't even taste half chocolate yeah
it smells like off-brand chocolate with
Hotel coffee
you know like hotel coffee like it's
free and it's in the lobby but it's not
good so you like put a little of your
hot chocolate pack it in to make like an
impromptu mocha but that's not good
either but you're tired so you drink it